dimanche 7 avril guyancourt certains se
sont levés très tôt pour participer à la
25e édition de la glu en course au
départ du gymnase des droits de l'homme
une course à pied de 10 km pour
l'occasion certains se sont fixé des
objectifs
c'est dans le meilleur de possibles et
d'essayer d'accrocher un podium mais
avec l'âge malheureusement sa vie est de
plus en plus difficile dans ce corpus
pour mon plaisir l'apport d'autres au
contraire sont moins ambitieux en tout
cinquante minutes ce sera bien un
programme anti c'est bien on tue tant
pis pour cette édition 2010 9 la course
recense près de 350 inscrits hommes et
femmes
je pense que les gens aiment bien ce
côté nature au bord de l'eau en se
mettant un petit challenge puis 25 ans
et le challenge un petit peu de l'année
pour pas mal de gens c'est j'aime et dix
kilomètres à faire donc je m'entraîne
pour faire cette course qui est proche
de chez moi c'est beaucoup de gens qui
sont vraiment la vie de nouvelles qui
viennent pour la course a finalement été
remporté par pierre-etienne charbonnel
le sportif a bouclé ses 10 km en 38
minutes 40 secondes pour sa première
participation
le deuxième est juste à queue devait pas
très loin on a fait dix bornes ensemble
puis je vais un peu décrochés sur le
sur le dernier kilomètre mais c'était
très bien chez les féminines c'est
l'argument courtoise audrey soulabaille
qui remporte la compétition avec un
temps de 43 minutes et 57 secondes se
contenter d'être la première voilà même
si ce n'est pas forcément un objectif
c'était juste prendre du plaisir
vraiment d'objectif juste la terminer ce
cas une petite côtelettes à mi parcours
qui est assez qui en publie un peu casse
pattes rendez vous l'année prochaine
pour une 26e édition les organisateurs
pourrait modifier légèrement le parcours
est intégrée de la marche nordique au
programme de l'événement